[Music]  sally the city is opening a new free  drive through coveted testing site that  will operate on weekends today is the  first day it's open that site is located  in the veterans memorial community  center parking lot that's on south  pavilion center drive in summerlin city  leaders say results are also pretty  quick here  these rapid tests get here get pretty  quick results within 15 minutes so if  you are positive they will call you and  let you know within 35 to 40 minutes  however if you're negative they'll let  you know by the end of the day  you don't need an appointment but you  can pre-register to speed things up it's  open both saturday and sunday from 8 in  the morning to 6 at night